[Music]
let's go to kristen
in san diego what's up kristin
good morning good morning oh it is
before
time began out in california thanks for
getting up so early with me
absolutely i'm really excited to talk to
you i have been a fan since day one and
i have listened to every podcast so i
make it a priority in life to listen to
you so you are so awesome
uh well thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you thank you so what's
up
well just to jump right in and try to
stay level and not to get too emotional
but it's your child so how do you not um
a few weeks ago my husband came to me
and said that he wants a divorce and i'm
really struggling with how do i tell our
six-year-old
oh six-year-old yikes all across the
board oh man
what happened
well
you know i could go
far back and and really have some truth
with myself and say did i ignore some
real core values when i think the spouse
was a young and looking for the son and
he was funny
attention and you know you overlooked
some really
like i said like the core values because
hey he makes me feel good maybe he's not
being as
nice to others as he should but he just
needs it or maybe i don't like the
choices that he made with that i
wouldn't do that but you know you make
excuses and
but recently uh hey kristen talk
directly into your phone for me
okay can you hear me that much better
much better okay
recently he's became real disconnected
he would lay on the couch
all day um
watch tv not interact with us
and um
we've never had a relationship where
we can effectively discuss problems it's
always like a shutdown it's kind of he
doesn't want to talk about it and i kind
of have to work on eggshells and conform
to his values and his warrants and
and you know i can i can go back and and
i think it's so new that i'm still
really evaluating the relationship and
also
the things
that went wrong and i think overall i
think i i did choose a poor spouse and
he loves uh
hold on hold on kristen
we can choose
i mean
i
i i don't think the emphasis is so much
on choice as much as
two adults acting like adults and
choosing as we go to be in good
relationship with one another and it
sounds like
choice or not you made the choice and he
has chosen over time
and
you may or may not have participated in
it but
if chosen to
not invest in this relationship is that
is that fair
very fair okay and so is he seeing
somebody else is he cheating on you is
he saying like i mean it doesn't i guess
he's saying i'm not going to cheat on
you anymore because i don't want to be
married to you anymore why is he
deciding now to leave
i think he's a very negative person i
think he makes rash decisions
i think he has like grandiose ideas he
may have some depression
i don't fully know
um he's always made me feel kind of
disposable okay and
um i'm not extremely shocked okay
is there a
tiny part of you
that
is kind of like yes
or
and i'm just like
kristen what have you been doing all
these years and i'm just like feeling
some freedom and like okay i need help
with myself why
i let the relationship navigate the way
it did and that's you know things that
i'll need to work on
and i just can't my whole concern is for
my daughter but for myself
selfishly like i'm excited okay that
that i mean that's um that's good to
know because that directs how how
we're gonna talk to her
um
so you have one six-year-old is he the
father of her
uh we actually adopted her from birth we
were in the delivery room so yes she is
all
we are all she knows okay
um
and you only have one
yes okay so when you're talking about a
six-year-old i want you to keep this
equation in your mind
a plus b equals me
okay and i got that from an
extraordinary child psychologist and it
stuck with me it's just
an important reminder here's what that
means
how mom feels and how dad feels
doesn't really matter all the reasons
why are not going to compete with the
six year old i had one friend who's a
child psychologist who said
she remembers very clearly when she was
10 and her parents totally were getting
divorced and her first question was can
we still go to arby's
okay
and so it's gonna be very concrete at
the same time her body's it's a it's a
bomb going off inside of her right
because everything she knows is gonna be
different even though
we sometimes use bombs to get rid of old
buildings right and to excavate sites
doesn't mean that over time this isn't
gonna be the best thing and the right
thing
your your response saying um i'm married
to someone who treats me less than who
has stepped out of this marriage a long
time ago who makes it makes us all right
so it's gonna be a good thing over time
um
but it's gonna be an explosive moment
okay so
don't be surprised if everything is the
questions that come are about her that's
developmentally appropriate it should be
if you're having this conversation with
a 17 year old it's a totally different
track okay
um here's the two things she's going to
want to know
what did she do to make this happen
and is she going to be safe meaning what
happens next okay okay
so um here's a couple of rules of thumb
one to two minutes per year
so this conversation this first one will
be 10 to 12 minutes and that's about it
okay okay not a lot of explanations not
a lot of oh this is and that's and and
and then mommy none of that
um it will be quick and if you can
you've heard me say this a lot um kids
we all do but kids especially absorb
power differentials so if you can get
down on her level look her in the eyes
okay
this works way way way better if your
husband acts like a mature adult and
will be in there with you
is that possible
yes he will he will really yes yeah he
he is with her
he really expresses his love and he does
for her so i know that we'll do it
together the conversations we've had is
he's been involved he's having ideas how
to tell her so okay um so we're gonna
sit down together on the floor with her
okay and we're gonna let her know this
is a very serious mom and dad
conversation
and the conversation will start with mom
and daddy love you we will always love
you and mom and daddy will never leave
you
and um and
mommy and daddy have made a grown-up
decision that we are going to get
divorced
so we are taking full even if you're
thinking inside actually i don't want to
be getting divorced now
we are going to take full ownership of
this thing and begin planting seeds now
they're going to bloom 10 years from now
15 years from now 20 years from now that
this is not her fault okay
so we're going to plant those seeds now
mommy and daddy made a grown up decision
and we are going we are going to get
divorced so that means you're going to
spend one week at mommy's house and
you're gonna spend one week at daddy's
house and then here's what i'm talking
about the concrete you're gonna have a
toothbrush at mommy's house and you're
gonna have a toothbrush at daddy's house
and you're gonna have friends at mom's
house and friends at daddy's house and
if you know the information like you're
going to stay in this school and you're
going to we're still going to have
morning breakfast on thursdays or
whatever the thing is
some really concrete really quick things
okay
and then check in with her
how does this feel in your body
how does this feel
tell me the words that are coming to
your heart she may talk a lot well are
we still gonna have christmas she may
have something like that she will
probably ask why
why
because it doesn't make any sense to a
kid that why would adults voluntarily
choose misery right why would you
voluntarily choose to have to split up
everything and move all that right so it
doesn't make sense
um
and that's okay the answer is to why is
this is not your fault and we both
really love you and we will never leave
you
okay we're not going to get into with a
six-year-old we're not going to get into
well daddy has been this and mom
we are made we made a grown-up decision
this is best for us
okay and just know that any of your
explanations are not going to register
with a six-year-old outside of we're
making adult decisions okay
okay
um
here's another hard one and this is a
conversation you can have with him and
you can tell him i said this directly to
your husband
uh my friend dr steve jennings um he's
he works he's
he's an expert working with men um but
he's worked with families for years
here's what he tells his clients and i
love it
he says
i tell a client
that right before you're about to say
something negative about your spouse who
you just got divorced with
i want you to find your kid and i want
you to punch him in the stomach as hard
as you can
oh my gosh okay
and then go ahead and tell them what
you're going to tell them about their
dad or about their mom
that's the level of violence both
physiologically and cognitive a kid
absorbs when they hear
that dad is the worst or your dad's
doing this or mom just kicked me out
right
right
here's why you've heard me say this
before on the show and i'll say it again
kids know that half of me is him and
half of me is her
and when we tell them and especially an
adoptive situation we opted into this
right and so this kid's gonna have even
more wait right so this is gonna be a
dicey situation for a while with this
youngster
they need to know i'm not talking bad
about dad even though you might think he
is the biggest scumbag ever or he's
gonna have he's gonna pop up in two
weeks with some new girlfriend or
whatever and you're gonna think i knew
it
that can't filter to her that's got to
be you with your adult friends your
adult counselors your adult grown-ups in
your life who are walking like doing
life with you is that you see what i'm
saying
yeah and he ha your husband can not
cannot
uh avoid a hard conversation with her
at the expense of you
and what i mean by that is he cannot say
well your mom just man she was tough to
be married to so i had to go
no he has to take ownership of his
actions i told your mother that i no
longer want to be married to her
but even though i'm not your mom's
husband
i will always be your daddy
okay
and we're gonna always loot back after
that 10 or 10 or 12 15 minute talk um
we're gonna
one or two of y'all are gonna take her
somewhere
because now she's going to want to test
it because y'all said y'all were going
to stay together forever and y'all are
breaking up but you're telling me you're
going to love me forever
maybe
right
and now that now now the next 5 10 15 20
years of testing begins
can i push you far enough that you're
gonna actually walk away from me too
and the answer to that has to be no both
of you right
okay
um so that means after that we're gonna
go to ice cream get ice cream
we're gonna go to the park
um daddy's gonna take you to go get a
hamburger
and
we're gonna go do something we're not
just gonna drop that bomb in 12 minutes
and then walk out and leave the
six-year-old in her room by herself
all right she's gonna and we're not
gonna talk a lot about it in the car
either we'll answer all of our questions
age-appropriately but we're not gonna
bring it up we're not gonna go over
we're not gonna go over
um
we're gonna show her love by connection
and attention we're gonna put our phones
away and we are just gonna go sit at a
table and in fact hang on the line i'm
going to send you all of the questions
for humans cards i have for kids and
parents and teens and kids all of those
and that'll give you something you can
do while you're out getting ice cream
together or something okay that was
going to be my next question if you had
any resources or advice on something to
read so i just thank you so much for
that actually i'm going to do this this
is a strange thing hold on
i'm pulling up um something i never do
um
but i'm pulling my phone out here my my
friend dr jennings sent me these two
books
um one is called my two homes
by um
alejandro pozzo stevenson
it's called my two homes and there's
another book called two homes filled
with love by steve herman
and she recommended this those two books
as great resources i'll link to them in
the show notes i've never read them i've
never opened them but she has this
conversation all the time
and she says they are excellent books
just to read to especially to a
six-year-old right oh okay um and we'll
link to in the show notes and you can
just pick them up on amazon um great and
uh but i i think having some direct
connecting connection time
and here's one last final thing
it is okay to tell her
that i'm very very sad
and daddy's very very sad
it's okay to say we had expected to be
married forever and we've made grown-up
decisions to not be married forever not
be married anymore
but your daughter's gonna feel very very
sad
mainly because she doesn't understand
mainly because she's all the abandonment
all the stuff right
um
and if she knows mom feels sad and dad
feels sad then she's gonna feel not
crazy
and so you being honest about how you
feel when it comes to grief um is going
to be important and by the way my guess
is y'all's marriage has been a mess for
a while is that fair
oh absolutely yeah
um i just kind of hit a lot of it and
made the best of it and
i think i was honest with myself about a
year ago and i said this is not who i
would choose this isn't the relationship
i would choose and knowing his
inability to even have
productive conversations he would never
work on it um so i kind of knew you know
this is the situation i'm in and i'm
going to write it out for my daughter
i'm almost thankful that she that he
did the hard thing and and decided you
know came to me and said no like this
marriage is over
to rip the band off now now
make no mistake i i have yet to see any
sort of data or research that would
suggest that
had you sat with him and said hey we are
intentionally choosing a life of misery
together
let's intentionally choose something
else
and that means um we're gonna have to
learn new skills
right and he said you're right i'm i'm
done choosing misery choosing immaturity
so i'm gonna choose maturity which
doesn't mean i'm gonna suddenly become a
great communicator overnight but that
means i'm gonna commit to learning how
to be like
that arc would have been much better for
everybody but it didn't happen yeah
right didn't happen so now we're dealing
with reality and your husband says he's
walking out on y'all and so you can
breathe for the first time in a long
time there will be healing in the how in
the home they'll be healing in your
daughter's heart no question about it
um
you and your husband are gonna have to
choose and maybe this is the
conversation you have with him
you and i have both chosen over the last
six seven eight nine years however long
we've been married
to not communicate well
we have chosen
to be
distant from one another we cannot do
that moving forward with our child
we're gonna have to choose to talk we're
gonna have to choose to be open with one
another when i say i don't want her
dating and you say i do want her dating
we're gonna have to sit down like adults
and have that conversation and not just
fire texts off back at each other right
you see what i'm saying you're gonna
have to have a level of intentionality
with your divorced relationship than you
did with your married relationship right
which sounds crazy because we could have
just done this five years ago we didn't
so here we are okay
to all you listening
um to this
here where this goes
right
here where this goes
to the men listening to this or watching
this
don't choose misery and that doesn't
mean leave
that means sit down across the table
or sit down on a couch next to the
person you said you love that you said
you can live forever
that you either made kids with you made
humans with or you adopted you created
you created a family unit
say i'm done choosing misery
will you be done choosing misery too can
we choose something way better than this
and i'm gonna have to learn some new
skills you're gonna have to learn some
new skills would you learn those with me
i promise i'll go first
and wives
you you hear the end here a woman who
said i wouldn't have picked him
and now i'm just gonna cash out the rest
of my life
i'm just gonna crawl under this blanket
and just stay here until this thing's
over
you get one shot you get one tiny little
life don't live like that
the institution of marriage just gets a
bad rap and these
if you will put the work in and the work
is hard it is hard it is hard and it's
new and it's shameful and it's
embarrassing and it's all that's
frustrating it's all those things
but i promise you compulsive spenders
and you're married to somebody who's
like why do you keep running us into the
ground financially
compulsive cheaters why what is it about
you that you think you're gonna find out
there
compulsive just sitting on the couch
grabbing five beers after work and
you're saying i'm out i'm out why
why choose that life
choose something different
and if you're married choose to do it
together
choose to do it together these kids they
need us